they arrived in Indonesia weak and tired
after a long dangerous Journey from
Bangladesh these rohinga refugees had
already come ashore in AR
Province but the message from locals was
clear you are not welcome here they were
given food and water before being forced
out to sea
again around 100 people took part in a
demonstration in the city of saang
voicing their frustration
with the new
arrivals it's one boat after another how
many boats have come here already we are
poor people why don't you use the money
to help us why are they giving them
food we reject the ringas we want them
to be moved as soon as possible we don't
want to catch the diseases they
carry a few meters away these refugees
are waiting in a shelter they lives in
limbo we just want to find somewhere
safe we knew that we might die at sea
but finally we are safe that's all we
want for our children for years rohinga
have fled persecution in Myanmar for
Bangladesh more recently many have fled
again traveling by boat to Southeast
Asia and for the most part they have
been welcomed by communities in Northern
Indonesia 3 years ago alaz reported on
how these locals helped refugees ashore
in defiance of
authorities but in recent weeks some
communities have been unwilling to
accept them please don't send us back to
see these rohinga plead before being
forced to return to their vat
Indonesia's government says it's looking
for a new site to temporarily hous the
refugees it's acknowledged the
opposition from residents and says it's
looking for a sustainable
solution the UN Refugee agency says the
increase in violence in camps in
Bangladesh as well as continued
instability in Myanmar is behind the
increase in boat Journeys around
75% of the new arrivals are women and
children so of the children quite a lot
are unaccompanied and separated meaning
they're traveling without their parents
or they're traveling
alone um quite a lot of single mothers
and their
children for now these children have
enough food and somewhere safe to sleep
but their future is uncertain they have
no passports no homes and no idea how
long they'll be allowed to stay here
Jessica Washington alzer
jakata make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer